dear kitten there's something that I
need to warn you about today is going to
get weird
you know how normally the humans sit in
front of that light box it's quite
lovely actually we just sit there for
hours and they don't disturb the little
people that live inside the light box at
all but on one day a year everything
changes oh come on it's just a doorbell
how many times do I have to tell you
it's like the human way of narrowing
outside of a closed door just lazier
okay fine I'll join you under the light
box stand dear kitten the first thing
that happens is all these new humans
arrive then they gather up every single
thing that we sleep on and then they try
to take up as much room as they can in
the dumbest looking way possible hey
kitten kitten check it out
I'm taking up all the room yeah you try
one like pretend you're a sausage that
lost its will to live that's the spirit
wait I got another one check me out
kitty got a big better but all joking
aside there is no place for us to nap we
are doomed
dear kitten after they have all
assembled in the room of comfortable
things they bring out her cornucopia of
human moisture oh I'm not totally sure
if the objective is to get it into or
near the mouth hole maybe it's like
bocce a like you get points for being
close it really goes everywhere on their
face I don't actually you have a little
something right there let me get that
all right calm down sir here's a lot
don't kill the messenger
dear kitten you see how some of the
humans are wearing traditional robes of
some sort I can't tell what they signify
in terms of status but I am pretty sure
that one is the idiot the humans seem to
have some sort of a ritual when the
light box suddenly gets loud all of the
humans try to be the first to jump up
and shout louder than anyone else the
person who gets up the fastest is the
winner and gets to hit people with his
paws the slowest people to get up are
then taunted for their inadequacies and
they become very sad it's actually quite
a cruel game
but it's a cruel world dear kitten
you've probably noticed these strange
metal cylinders it seems to be a device
that the humans used to suck out their
intelligence kind of like the vacuum but
instead of sucking dirt it sucks out
judgment and common sense look-see yes
sure one time I tried it by accident and
you know what the next morning I woke up
feeling terrible wearing another cat's
collar and I may or may not have been
inside of a sock don't ask because I
don't remember
dear kitten I know with this sort of
madness your instinct is to hide but
there's a bigger play here I need you
right up in there I mean jump on peoples
labs and try to walk across the table of
sloppy sauces if you can find someone
who sneezes every time you get near them
get near them and when it's time you
just walk right in front of the light
box and sit down like you don't know
what's going on and then 3 2 1 that's
right
kitty get an airplane ride a little
private jet to the only prize worth
competing for a can of moist delicious
wet food and touchdown works every time
did he get what he wants
fly a kitty fly